me roux plus grande que nature peinte à
même le trottoir et des élus qui se
pressent aux roues dans roues sur le
pont wilson un symbole et un nouveau
coup de projecteur sur le vélo à près de
100 jours du passage du tour de france
dans la cité tourangelle
pour le maire écologiste de tours finies
les polémiques sur le côté machiste et
polluant de la grande boucle
nous on est pour cet événement populaire
cette grande fête populaire
et bien sûr on veut qu'ils continuent
mais on veut aussi qu'il fasse sa
mutation écologique et bien les choses
changent puisque pour l'accueil des des
vainqueurs à la fin de l'étape
maintenant on a un binôme paritaire qui
accueille est qui et qui donne les
trophées donc ça c'est quelque chose de
positif
et puis depuis quelques semaines il a
été annoncé que les couloirs ont
interdiction j'ai des déchets en dehors
des zones qui sont prévus pour mais là
en plus il y aura des pénalités en terme
de temps donc vraiment ça veut dire que
l'excellence et l'exemplarité écologique
elle rentre dans cette compétition une
course devenue vertueuse donc et de
multiples festivités en prévision pour
montrer les relations d'amitié qui
unissent la ville de tours et la petite
reine
reste une inconnue de taille le coville
19 pourrait-il jouer les trouble fête
on ne connaît pas encore les règles
sanitaires qui s'imposeront à nous à ce
moment là l'objectif on l'espère tous
ses pouvoirs faire une grande fête
populaire le 1er juillet mais pas que le
1er juillet c'est de rythme et avant
pendant et après la relation avec ces
grands événements sportifs avec le vélo
le vélo des champions mais aussi le vélo
du quotidien le départ de cette 6e étape
sera donné le 1er juillet devant la
bibliothèque municipale
les coureurs les vrais s'élanceront en
direction de château